good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy hump day it is
Wednesday here we are excited we are
feeling a little you know coming off of
Valentine's Day right into hump day
feeling kind of uh excited if you know
what I mean hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing well we're feeling that Amorous
Spirit over here at The Thirst you know
what it's giving
what amore
that's beautiful Claudia
thanks how was your big V day oh you
know what it was fabulous me and Ben
went to dinner we went out to Katsuya
which like I feel like throwback it's
giving like the hills like I feel like
they used to eat there in L.A do you
think that you went there because you
were watching Laguna Beach 100 I also
went there because it's close to Madison
Square Garden like it's on 30th and 11th
it's like Hudson yards so I honestly had
very low expectations but I have to say
it was absolutely fabulous and I feel
like the the amount of fabulous places
in this town is dwindling and when I
find one I want to share it it was also
very toasty lots of toasters so you know
you're eating amongst like-minded people
which is so important always nice and
then we saw Billy Joel I will say I
think I might need like a Billy Joel
break
because
um and I get it like you know Billy Joel
has like you know hundreds of songs
and you know there's like 15 that
everyone loves and he has to do you know
multiple shows a year and he does want
to keep playing the same 15. and he does
but like he really has to like he played
so many more so than any other time so
many like like Unknown songs like my
section was sitting the whole time until
the Encore which is like never a good
sign you know
how many times have you been to Billy
Joel this might be like my third or
fourth but the last two times were like
in the span of six months
okay
that's a lot of Joel it was great and
he's great and he's so um like energized
and you don't really he's like in his
70s he was talking about how he was born
in 1949 I'm like holy [__] you're one
year younger than the state of Israel
like it was crazy
um
but I just felt like you know like play
the hits come on
especially on the day play the love
songs even though the hits aren't really
love songs that's what he was saying he
like started out he's like all right I'm
gonna do a bunch of songs about love I
don't really like have that many but
here you go yeah so it was good it was
great it was also like a great thing to
do on Valentine's Day I feel like
everyone just like does dinner and like
candles but I don't know it's like a fun
activity that is fun I'm glad you had a
fun time how was your V day oh let's
talk about an update from yesterday did
you get flowers because I didn't I was
[__] pissed so yes technically I got
flowers
um because and I didn't want to complain
because you know flowers are flowers
technically but Zach had to run to the
grocery store to get Harry some milk and
he did bring me some grocery store roses
I don't want to criticize because I
didn't even get and then when we sat
down for dinner I literally said to Ben
I'm like I shouldn't even have to ask
this like where are my flowers
and he was like oh my God I forgot I'm
always so good with the flowers I'm so
sorry and I just said
it's unacceptable you have one job and I
didn't realize how important flowers are
to you on Valentine's Day like to me I'm
all or nothing like either we're going
to dinner you're getting me flowers and
a gift or
forget about it I just I'm in like in
the last few years I feel like gifts for
me in the place that I'm in my life like
gifts are so unnecessary and Ben loves
giving gifts but I've told him like I
don't need anything it's so wasteful
like don't get me gifts but that doesn't
mean I don't want to occurred in some
flowers yeah oh curd yeah curds well by
the wayside yesterday but we're making
plans for our anniversary because we
really we didn't like do anything
yesterday we just like acknowledged each
other I got my grocery store flowers
um but we're gonna put it all to Friday
because like oh my God we have no energy
I can imagine but it's important you got
to make time for each other I know I
know but you know we have a one-year-old
so it's just
it's crazy times no for sure and like I
totally I believed Ben when he said he
forgot like I don't think he had bad
intentions he was like and I know he's
like so stressed and so busy with work
like Spritz stuff they're like raising
money like I and I get it like and I see
when he comes home from work like how
stressed he is so I'm not minimizing
that but I'm sorry it's unacceptable and
it's like you guys we're celebrating
Valentine's Day like you made plans I'm
sure you made the reservation I'm sure
you got the tickets like I did he had
one job what he just showed up does he
expect to be like wined and dined on
Valentine's Day like what did he do to
contribute to Valentine's Day I'm so
glad you brought that up because we
talked about this before bed he's like
but I made the reservation uh sir I
literally asked you for a week to make
the reservation a week I texted you so
many times reminding you about it of
course you did not do it and then on
Monday night you made the reservation
and then we ended up changing it the day
of so I don't know that's like I'm I'm
not swept away by that no I'm not I'm
not swept away by that for you and like
if I was in if I if this was like two
years ago and Zach and I were married
but like we didn't have kids and like we
were celebrating Valentine's Day like I
would not be happy no and I Ben is so
extreme like either he has to buy me you
know a home
or I get nothing and it's like I don't
want either like I don't want a new
person I just want flowers and I know
when I get home today I know like
biggest Arrangement and you're gonna get
some flowers that were on sale and some
chocolate hearts I told him I said
please do not send me flowers tomorrow
there is nothing sadder and will make me
feel like a bigger [__] loser than
getting flowers on Wednesday please do
not do it and also it's like whatever
happened to you know sending flowers to
your girl at work like
I know dream big but imagine you walked
to the studio and like there were
flowers waiting for you we were and you
were genuinely surprised I love flowers
and I think maybe that's why I don't
really like that Miley Cyrus song
because yeah I could buy myself flowers
but don't make me
yeah I agree it's not about the money
spent it's about like no the thought
behind them and who is sending them
honestly I don't think there's a moment
in like a woman's life that makes you
feel more special than like coming home
and there's like a road and you don't
know who it's from and you have to look
at the card and you're like oh my God he
was thinking of me like it's so special
and Ben took that away for me
I'm glad you could come on here and
you know vent yeah and I vented to bed
last night like I like he felt so bad so
like I felt bad like hounding him but
I'm sorry it's unacceptable unacceptable
I understand
he's definitely gonna try and do
something to make it up for it and it's
just going to make it worse 100 I told
him last time I do not I'm like let's
just let bygones with bygones don't let
it happen again please do not do
anything extreme yeah
he will
um but we have a great show today
because it's Wednesday which means we're
gonna be helping out some toasters in
need we've got three submissions from
three girls who are just desperate for
some good old Jackson Claude advice and
we're gonna do our best we will I feel
like we've been giving good advice
recently so I'm excited to see what
you've got for us we've also got some
gorgeous Diaries gorgeous stories I'm
excited to talk about them me too so
whatever you want to do yeah
I think goodness gracious okay without
further Ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know without further Ado about
all the things our husbands didn't do
yesterday with all the things our
husbands didn't do
here we're gonna move on with our year
and they can try again next year best of
luck yes
um today's episode is brought to you by
nutrifall 30 million women are impacted
by weakened or thinning hair if you're
among them know that you're not alone
and there is a solution that you can
trust to deliver results nutrifall is
the number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement it's clinically
shown to improve your hair growth your
hair thickness and visible scalp
coverage nutrifall supports healthy hair
growth from within it targets the five
root causes of thinning hair which is
stress hormones environment nutrition
and metabolism and it does that through
whole body health I feel like a lot of
women like through different times like
obviously postpartum but if you're going
through something really stressful like
an unintended consequence of that is
your hair thinning and it's what by the
time you realize like it's almost you
feel like it's too late but it's not
neutrophone has three unique formulas to
support women throughout all stages of
life including postpartum and menopause
each formula is physician formulated
using natural drug-free medical grade
ingredients and it is consistently
effective dosages that you are getting
the most reliable results in a clinical
study 86 percent of women reported
improved hair growth after six months
and over three thousand Top Doctors and
stylists recommended neutrofall as an
effective and high quality hair solution
for healthier hair you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to neutralfall.com entering the
promo code toast and saving 15 off your
first month's subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time free shipping and Returns on every
order as well get 15 off at
nutrifall.com that's spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by our Queens over at the perfect bar if
you're looking for a protein bar that
actually tastes good we'll look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here they're made with
freshly ground nut butter organic honey
and 20 organic superfoods perfect bar
has a variety of products like protein
bars and little snack size bars too that
are also good and good for you you are
sure to find something you love a
personal favorite of ours is the dark
chocolate chip peanut butter it has a
little sea salt a couple flecks on top
it's so good I love that perfect bars
are kept in the fridge that's how you
know that they are truly made with like
organic healthy ingredients and real
ingredients that taste like real
ingredients they have a cookie dough
texture that are creamy and full of
flavor and they're unlike any other bars
out there and they come in a snack size
too so it's perfect for just you know
heading out the door throwing in your
purse your fabulous gal on the go oh
sorry I gotta grab my perfect bar before
I go throw it in my gorgeous purse uh
they're made with whole food ingredients
no artificial preservatives
they're also non-GMO project verified
gluten-free soy-free kosher and low GI
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or PayPal account which is pretty
sickening all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast t-o-a-s-t to get a free
perfect bar today happy snacking thank
you turdy you're welcome okay our first
story some Valentine's Day new couple
news
emrata and Eric Andre share steamy pics
from naked Valentine's Day date Eric
Andre posted photos of him and his
rumored girlfriend Emily Ratajkowski
hanging out in the buff on Instagram for
Valentine's Day he wrote Happy
Valentine's Day it's a picture of him
naked on a couch with a heart emoji
covering his penis meanwhile emrata is
in the background you can see her in the
mirror taking the picture of naked as
well
it's a lot why did you choose this story
because now I have I have no choice I
chose this story because she's on our
list of eligibles she's confirming she's
with a new man
um and she's confirming in a really big
way that doesn't leave any room for
ambiguity or maybe they're just business
partners
so like I know we live no this is how
you and even though this is how you and
I usually conduct our business meetings
a hundred percent
I know we live in a day and age where
like we can do all this stuff you know
we can be naked on Instagram and be
disgusting but just because we can
begs the question does that mean we
should
and I
I'm sorry like I thought you know what I
don't I don't want to be like like
negative and judgmental but like I don't
know I saw this picture I'm like this is
gross like this house looks dirty like I
just like I was like I can't even
imagine what's on that couch like there
was a butthole on the couch like I don't
know like I just these are two people
who are like successful and like I had a
certain image of them in my mind and now
I think they're gross sorry like I hate
to be so negative I don't know if I'm
gonna get like backlash for that like
this was gross
I do agree I mean like any new
relationship they were spotted at the
the basketball game basketball game Go
songs at the basketball game
I was about to say like baseball I don't
know yeah yeah yeah they were spotted
the game and it was like oh are they
aren't they because you know she was
just with pig Davidson and she's like
The Bachelorette of New York City so it
was like cute and like you know keeping
us on our toes yeah and now there is
zero mystery bring back the mystery yeah
I don't know what it is with people it's
like it's nothing sacred anymore like
don't get me wrong like yes I know that
people who are romantically involved
probably walk around their houses naked
together I have been married like I know
that these things happen I never really
have any interest in seeing other people
do it you know what I mean no and like
some things are meant for the privacy of
your own life I know and I don't know
something about this photo I don't know
if it was like the red couch that was
giving like very Playboy mansions and
it's not red it's um dark gray
oh my God I could have sworn it was a
red couch Mandela effect I don't know
and like the really cluttered house in
the back like it was just it was giving
it was giving like sty you know
no the pigsty Oh I thought you meant
like a stye in your eye I was like why
because like if someone lays on the
ground where his butt was 100 it's
appropriate there too it applies
um I don't know I just like the whole
the whole thing was gross no I hate to
be negative but that's how I felt I
agree
um
but I guess they're together so what do
you think about the coupling
like I don't care oh okay who is that
he's an actor comedian his face is so
familiar so familiar he's in a lot of
stuff he's also in a lot of animated
stuff which wouldn't explain why his
face is familiar but for me I best know
him from The Internship
got it okay uh who does he play in The
Internship he plays just like one of the
higher ups at Google who's very googly
and who's always on their case oh sorry
I was thinking of The Intern
also incredible but Google is in the
intern okay I understand what you're
saying
um I don't care like I honestly I'm I'm
not I feel like there are a lot of women
out there
who are in emrata's Target demographic
and I believe I am the antithesis of her
demographic yeah
I agree
same so like she doesn't do it for me
and I don't care
okay well she's uh she's coupled up so
we'll take her off the list and I'm
happy that these two have found love and
such what is clearly such like a
meaningful way because they're going all
the way well I I also do think part of
this I have to imagine is like a a big
middle finger to her ex like you know he
cheated on her right and
she's like I think a little bit at least
just like shoving it in his face and
that's something I can get on board with
yeah
but the whole world is also watching
like I don't know yeah no it's a lot
it's just a lot it's a lot yeah but um
hopefully the Love is Real
yeah
are you ready for our next story
some movie news probably Blockbuster
movie news because Lady Gaga is seen as
Harley Quinn For the First Time In The
Joker sequel photo yes we have gotten a
sneak peek at Lady Gaga and Joaquin
Phoenix's big screen Bad Romance to
celebrate Valentine's Day on Tuesday
Warner Brothers released the first
official look image from the two actors
in Joker falia do the upcoming musical
excuse me it's called Joker
uh Colin
f-o-l-i-e space o l i e okay space a
with an apostrophe on top uh-huh space
d-e-u-x
fully I do fully I do okay the upcoming
musical sequel to the Oscar winning 2019
film The Joker uh she is playing Harley
Quinn while he is reprising his role as
the Joker and they another romantic
story between these two who knew she was
playing Harley Quinn in this Joker
sequel yeah I don't know if them
releasing the photo was like an
announcement or people had already known
that I don't really keep up with like
you know those types of movies yeah
um I love this for Lady Gaga like this
kind of franchise is giving very much
like Marvel DC like these are real major
Blockbuster films and she's really in
the last year
cemented herself as like an actress she
really is like a triple threat and
I'm so glad you brought up Lady Gaga
because yesterday I had some down time
and it did go down like a rabbit hole of
watching Super Bowl halftime shows I
watched Katy Perry's and Lady Gaga's
and in terms of like how I remember them
like I remember Katy Perry's as being
like and it was
but Lady Gaga's was even better than I
imagined like she did [__] everything
she flew through the sky with the
greatest of ease she's saying she danced
she played that like guitar piano a
little thing she had like a quiet moment
with the piano you're giving me a
million reasons to let you go it was
just she also like you know
she was just it was everything like she
gave even all of herself she was also
being crazy she was being psychotic when
she throws the ball and jumps at the end
yep and when she jumped off the roof oh
my to start yeah but it was so she
started off with God Bless America and
these drones behind her Were Meant to
look like stars and then they all
changed to red white and blue and
created a flag and it was really it was
it had everything it was beautiful yeah
I agree Katy Perry's was more like
commercial yes yes and it was so
um
like kitschy almost like tongue-in-cheek
but I loved it I remember watching it
and I loved it I'm sure if I watched it
back I loved it but Lady Gaga's was a
little more like artistic oh and like
Katy Perry did bring out Lenny Kravitz
to sing a song with her and Missy
Elliott I forgot about the Missy Elliot
part who did like two songs with her so
it really wasn't like a one-woman show
in the way that Lady Gaga's was
yes agreed but they did we did have a
headliner our choice was made yeah yeah
um also Lady Gaga's been pretty quiet
recently so I guess she's been filming
her movie I think it's gonna be a huge
movie because the first one was huge too
yeah and by the way she's always like
you know starting rumors with her
Leading Men like do is Joaquin Phoenix
single no I think he's with Rooney Mara
yeah me too that's like such an iconic
dark couple iconic and they've been
together
Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly wish
they were as dark authentically as
Rooney Mara and one team walking Phoenix
because those are two like authentically
Twisted individuals very natural and I
feel like Megan Fox and Megan Kelly are
just like playing a part of leg yes we
are sharing blood of a pack yeah also
Megan Fox Kelly are they're doing like a
lot right now like they were seen like
leaving a couple's counseling bill yeah
that was really but they are spending
Valentine's Day together the whole thing
everyone who fell for it not me because
I wasn't going to choose it as a story
um they're together and they're just
being annoying no they have what started
out as like kind of like everyone's
shipping being obsessed has turned into
like they're like giving PR
yeah everything they do
well it makes sense because the initial
relationship and the initial love was
great for PR you know and it really
revitalized them we were just talking
about that like it was so good
individually for both of them and I
think it was like they really did fall
in love so it was really a win-win and
then I think they just got so used to
that level of Fame that it became so
manufactured and it's so like annoying
to see yeah
agreed um I love this choice for Lady
Gaga I know she's really kind of um
I think I think she's really hunting an
Oscar she's won one for music but I
think for acting I think everyone
thought House of Gucci was going to be
that for her and it wasn't I don't know
it like Joaquin Phoenix was nominated
for the Joker um I don't know if this is
really the type of role you get
nominated for I think she could be
nominated if her performance is amazing
but it's not like a shoe-in like House
of Gucci is kind of like a type of movie
where you get nominated yeah this is
like you know touch and go but a happy
for everyone that there's a sequel I
never saw the first one I wouldn't I
mean I probably won't see this but I
would maybe see it because Lady Gaga's
in it yeah yeah that's true she's
bringing a whole new demo she is I
wonder if her and Joaquin got along I
feel like they did they did they're
probably really similar in a sense
they're like you know Fame artists
artists experience Fame really young
they're both like a little troubled you
know emotional artists yeah that's I
could see them getting along I also
couldn't really see Joaquin doing a
movie with someone that he doesn't get
along with and because like this is his
movie he did the first one and like you
know there's no joker sequel without
Joaquin like I could imagine he had a
say in who got this part like who he
wants to work with yeah
totally random like change of subject
tangent do you ever feel like I'm alone
in the studio right now do you ever feel
like you're not alone like I can't
explain it I feel like a presence in
this room I feel like there's a mouse I
have no proof but I just feel like I'm
sharing the space with a rodent I can
feel it
so if you see me like looking around not
at you today I'm feeling like a creature
in my presence or maybe it's like the
spirit of somebody who passed I feel
like Teresa Caputo who's the young man
who passed suddenly
oh I do feel this I mean that's why I'm
feeling like scared and this ghost of
Snee just passes like a relationship and
scary yeah it's not like it's not a
friendly spirit it's definitely someone
you know haunted Casper no no it's not
Casper I would feel lighter than air if
Casper was in here today no of course
no I'm just I just I'm putting it out
there I feel a presence in the room
presence wait I'm gonna hold the sands
presence make yourself known
no I'm kidding
I scared myself oh my God
I really thought like a light would
flicker honestly like that would be so
crazy or maybe it's just a mouse
yeah probably and like if the light
flickers because like he chewed through
the cord you know 100 hopefully our
connection stays strong though yeah
hopefully he doesn't touch my ethernet
cable hopefully he doesn't cause a lag
that would cause us to lash out at one
another hopefully I hopefully there's no
lashing out due to a lag that would be
terrible
due to a mouse with a lag
the mouse with the lag
children's book are you ready for our
next story yeah speaking of children the
story like I found to be very disturbing
um I don't know I don't know if you saw
this but we were just talking about
Justin Timberlake's Super Bowl
performance selfie kid
oh no has been arrested in a mall fight
the selfie kid who snapped a viral photo
with Justin Timberlake at the end of the
singer's 2018 Super Bowl halftime show
spent his past Super Bowl weekend very
differently Ryan McKenna who's now 18
was arrested Saturday at a shopping mall
in Naples Florida where he was allegedly
drunk and fighting with friends inside a
CPK according to TMZ honestly sounds
like an iconic night out drunk at cbk I
think but I guess he's I keep
associating him as like 15 12 year old
no 15 but he's 18. so I guess 18 year
olds you know do drink but he like he
shot to stardom after he took his selfie
and now he's just like all right I guess
we're you know using the word stardom
fast and loose these days we are we are
like what he achieved him how many
followers does he have turdy
I'm going to look I just remember and I
remember we we talked about it selfie
kid
um
was like coming off the heels of a lot
of like really viral moments that
happened so organically and selfie kid
felt like he was kind of like an
industry plant like no one was making
him go viral and everyone was like the
selfie kid has gone viral it's like
really we're not talking about him no
totally he's so manufactured okay he has
445k I thought he was in the millions
um this is literally like the weirdest
story like I know I don't even know what
to say like because I was like better or
selfie kid do better do better selfie
kid like he had such opportunity and he
did he apparently a 15 year old boy
greeted cops at the restaurant and
reportedly told them that he and the
social media star who was his friend had
been in an argument that escalated with
selfie kid allegedly standing up and
aggressively pushing their table he
supposedly screamed obscenities at The
Boy's girlfriend too wait let me ask you
a question how did like who put together
that like this random 18 year old
relatively unknown kid Ryan McKenna was
the selfie kid like who's reporting this
TMZ original was TMZ so are they they
have like a database of like people with
remotely famous names and if they come
up in any sort of like police like who
would be looking for this who would put
it together because I couldn't tell you
selfie kids first not even less just
first name I could not tell you it if
you paid me 100 million dollars agreed I
don't know I don't know who put this
together because I feel like this is
something like he could have got
arrested and like you know years later
like he could have shared that he had
been arrested like we didn't know you
know what I mean breaking news also I
she's worth noting that selfie kid's
mother told the outlet that her son was
not under the influence and he was play
fighting with his friend after one of
them pulled his chair out from under him
sure
whatever you say Mom
do better selfie kid like I'm really
disappointed in you okay educate
yourself and like for the fellow diners
at CPK they deserve better yeah I hope
that they all got you know their meals
properly compensated and they probably
didn't yeah maybe it was one of the
diners who recognized him
perhaps it was a perhaps it was a big
loser at CPK that night because who
would recognize selfie kid five years
later like three whatever
he looks pretty this is similar so funny
like I can't I literally feel like I'm
high I'm like this is so dumb like
I feel like I literally smoked pot
oh my God
so good that's really [__] you can only
find out here at the toast we are so
special we are so different we are and I
feel like since we were just talking
about Super Bowl halftime shows no it's
I'm just talking about selfie kid and
like I'm surprised we didn't ask like
where's selfie kid now because we don't
care because we don't care
I wonder if he does like any social
media like stuff if he's monetized his
brand you know I think if he ever were
to write a book drunk at CPK would be a
good title for it yeah I'd read it
or it would be like a play on the word
selfie like self
ish from selfie to selfless
totally my journey to finding Christ or
something like that
looks like he's just chilling with his
friends
good living a normal life taking lots of
selfies I hope oh yeah yeah I guess
that's his thing that is the that was a
bad that was just bad like yeah take a
selfie that's so cute he's 15 years old
and he's had the Super Bowl and Justin
Timberlake walked past him but for like
then him to go on Ellen because he took
a selfie like what's wrong with everyone
no how low is the bar you know yeah I
wonder what Justin Timberlake thinks of
him
okay
I'm sure he [__] hates him yeah
because I feel like Justin Timberlake is
like a massive like [__] Diva like ego
Maniac yeah and anything that like takes
a spotlight off of him during his big
night
I'm sure he was I'm sure he was like
throwing classes against the wall also
like selfie kid doesn't not look like
him
yeah no they were definitely like you
know
seeing each other it's a similar Vibe oh
my God yeah like then at like the
iHeartRadio Music Festival in 2018
selfie could like took another selfie
with Justin Timberlake OH Justin
Timberlake and Justin Timberlake just
like
yeah Justin Timberlake but you heard it
here versus Justin Timberlake hates
selfie kid Justin Timberlake is the one
who called TMC he is a Google assistant
oh my God
waiting to cancel him literally that's
such a good call to put an end to this
long nightmare once and for all and the
madness
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah which is kind of the opposite news
to selfie kid being drunk at CPK okay
Lucy Hale has celebrated one year of
sobriety after a private journey of
self-love you know what I saw this on
her Instagram because we follow each
other
and I was like oh one year who is she
dating because the last time we spoke
about her she was taking those stage
pictures with um Colton
at Runyon County now last time we spoke
about her she was dating Skeet Ulrich
was she oh my God I don't even remember
that yeah they went on some dates oh
that's like kind of cute but like a
little agent appropriate
um no she's 33 she can date who she
wants oh 33 I guess yes I will always
see her as Arya like 12 years old yeah
so I was like oh man who is she dating
and then I read the caption and I was
like so weirdly like proud and happy for
her I'm like that's amazing
agreed I had the same experience uh she
marked one year of sobriety last month
the star told her Instagram followers
that's me and Claudia in an alternate
alternative Valentine's Day post on
Tuesday
that she has abstained from alcohol
since January 2022. she said this is a
post about self-love and about the
greatest thing I've ever done on January
2nd 2023 I celebrated one year of
sobriety while this journey has mostly
been private I felt compelled to let
anyone who is struggling know that you
are not alone and you are loved uh she
got a ton of support from her former PLL
co-stars on her Instagram and I just
thought that was awesome me too I was so
like moved by that I love that for her I
feel like
it's so hard to do especially in
Hollywood where like you know temptation
is everywhere and and really in order to
like get ahead you always have to be
like hobnobbing and drinking and
partying with these different people and
it's so toxic and you know what I just I
loved this I'm so happy for her I really
wish her the best on her sobriety
Journey yeah me as well
not as much as like I wish her more well
than you you think so I kind of feel
like I know you guys follow each other
but I kind of feel like I'm the bigger
fan you actually are like a huge Lucy
hell fan like you watch every show she
comes out with that never gets renewed
for a second season Queen yeah except
for that one that was on CW I didn't
watch that but I watched Katie Keane
yeah
um and every movie like if it's Lucy
Hale I'm watching it did you see her in
the hating game no it was like one of my
spicy books that they turned into a
movie and she played the girl and the
girl's name in the book was Lucy and I
just feel like the concept of that book
I hate enemies to lovers oh my God I
love enemies to lovers that's like my
least favorite Trope so I just for that
reason it wasn't like a Lucy thing it
was a me thing the movie was good
um but for enemies to lovers is not my
favorite Trope it's a good one my
favorite Trope is like childhood
childhood best friends borderline lovers
big drama they don't speak for years
reconnect in their late 20s do you think
that you have a personal interest in
that because of Maverick
you are so sick and twisted like no do
you think that Ben didn't get you
flowers because he knows like how you
feel about Maverick he's like because he
knows it's a fruitless Endeavor because
he's like wow does a Maverick get you
flowers oh you want flowers so bad I'll
tell Maverick
um perhaps maybe I'll when we when we
fight about it later I'll I'll bring
that up and see if that played any sort
of let me ask you roll let me ask you
something else please if if you just
said to Ben the word maverick would he
have any idea what that means uh you
know what
should I just text him and be like do
you know what Maverick is say do you
know who Maverick is that's such a great
question like I don't know because he
like never listens to this podcast but
he read your book
he did
do you know who Maverick is question
mark all right I'll keep you all updated
on he actually has like an important
meeting at 11 he's definitely not going
to answer but
we tried I think this is more important
I think so too I think you should step
out of the meeting
[Laughter]
you should probably postpone it
oh you're cracking me up today turd we
are being funny today yeah are you ready
for our fifth and final story
yeah I see you checking your phone
wondering by the way I my phone's on do
not disturb so I wasn't checking I was
kind of just like giving a sexy shoulder
so I looked left fine you know what I
mean I really wasn't looking at my phone
oh okay literally I was also just I was
scouring the food for mice literally
sure
you are so disgusting let me see if you
answered no
our fifth and final story is some
actually big news for kids today and
kids from the 90s
because Barney is back [__] Barney is
back and snatched Mattel is relaunching
the iconic purple dinosaur for kids and
adults okay calm down about the adults
yeah Mattel is putting a fresh spin on
the Barney franchise the toy company is
planning to revitalize the famous purple
dinosaur with a new presence across TV
film YouTube and kids products such as
toys books and clothes the company said
the Barney relaunches the latest example
of Mattel mining the incredible depth
and breadth of its IP portfolio to
relaunch Heritage franchises AKA they
can't find new ideas so they're going
into the archives no actually let me
tell you how I think this is really
smart no I think this is a good idea and
like I don't think this is because they
couldn't think of anything better but I
think you know you can build a brand
around like a kids you know uh pet
monkey and it'll be popular but
to revitalize a brand that people that
the people who were obsessed with are
now probably moms and dads so it's like
all right I'm buying my kids a toy oh I
grew up with Barney or this newfangled
vampire like I'm gonna go with Barney
you know no 100 and I know Barney and I
know what he stands for and I don't have
to I trust him but yeah I trust him and
it's like we watch Barney and we turned
out great like you want that same thing
for your kids and I feel like even when
I've thought about like what I want to
turn on for Harry it's like well what
did I watch I watch Barney like how can
I give him Barney so I'm so so here for
this and I just hope that like the
Barney we know and love and the
Integrity of Barney stays the same like
of course they modernized his look they
chiseled his jawline a lot of people
were joking that he got in on the Buckle
flat removal Trend because his jowls are
completely gone but he still you know
our plus-sized King oh my God literally
nobody has done more for the body
positivity movement than Barney yeah so
I just hope that they don't change too
much about him they just like they have
the new look he'll be on YouTube he'll
have his TV and movies and of course it
will be like more HD than what we used
to watch but like I want those same
messages a friendship of Love of love I
love you you love me we're a happy
excuse me family with the great big hug
and a kiss from me to you won't you say
you love me too yeah no beautiful
message and it kind of became this
springboard this kind of like Mickey
Mouse Club for young Talent you know
Selena Gomez was a Barney actor and so
was Demi Lovato like it was this
breeding ground for stardom and I don't
know maybe maybe we gotta send Harry
um
maybe we do but we also have to remember
that like things what got took a dark
turn with Barney well did that
documentary ever come out it it did come
out I believe um just because it's been
so long and I don't know that anyone
watched it okay because they said
someone was releasing a documentary that
there was a dark side to Barney no not
to Barney but to the
um the fandom like the title was I love
you you hate me and it was about the
hate that Barney received the death
threats the threats on his life actually
it would be really kind of interested to
see that documentary and I I have to say
maybe you know this timing is not so
coincidental on Mattel's part kind of
trying to
and make people forget about some of the
things that came out in that documentary
I can't I don't think anything came out
that was damning about Barney himself or
even like the set that he cultivated
right that's what I thought the
documentary was going to be about it's
like oh no toxicity about a TV show that
mainly casted kids kill me yeah
yeah but it wasn't right yeah it was
like some errant fans because like
Barney's someone that like you know you
could lose your mind over
uh I mean I get it we did we were
obsessed obsessed this is what they said
in creating the new series it was
important to us that we properly reflect
the world that kids today live in so
that the series can deliver meaningful
lessons about navigating it with our
modern take on Barney we hope to inspire
the Next Generation to listen care and
dream big we think that parents many of
whom will fondly remember the original
Barney from their own childhoods will
love the show too it's a brilliant
marketing move tell them the
heartstrings of the kids and the parents
I think Barney's about to be relaunches
another billion dollar brand from Mattel
good for them agree but not too modern
Barney
no the the thing with with kids shows is
like you really it's a simple formula
you know yeah and the ones that have
been around forever
they all do the same [__] you know
yeah yeah I just like I don't want to
see radical Barney that's not what I
want to see I kind of would love that
like Barney going off the deep end like
kind of obsessed like Barney is a
socialist from our imagination wait how
did that song Go Barney is a dinosaur
from our imagination
when he's on his way
some sensation
fire Bops let's keep up the fireball
Bops with this you know Barney 2.0 yeah
like the bar is high for Barney and so
while I'm so here for this move I think
it's brilliant yeah no you're right
don't [__] it up
in the words of the late not late the
great RuPaul good luck and don't [__] it
up literally are we ready to dive into
Deer toasters my absolute favorite part
of the week Born Ready the reason why I
get out of bed on Mondays
on Mondays
yeah like knowing like okay it's back to
work but at least I'll be saving lives
on Wednesday oh wow yeah I didn't know
that's how you like plan your week yeah
no there's a lot you don't know about me
Jackie I just take things day by day
you're such a day by day girl
um today's uh do your toes
are toast to you by vegamore
we have tried everything to get silky
and more listen up folks clean hair care
that's what I've been using we have
tried everything to get silky strong and
healthy hair and when we say everything
we mean everything hair masks avocado
masks anything so if you're tired of
those ineffective hair treatments and
are hungry to try something that
actually works give vegamore a try like
we did vigamort has transfer transformed
our hair their clean and vegan approach
to hair health uses smart Botanicals
that promote visibly thicker fuller and
longer looking hair with help from
vegamore you can get healthy beautiful
looking hair without the use of any
harmful chemicals all of their products
are cruelty free and they never contain
potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or harm hormones I know you are
in your clean era like you are only
bringing in tell me a little bit about
your experience with vegamore I will
because I found out recently that my
go-to shampoo and conditioner is not
clean it has fragrance which has hormone
disruptors and can just mess your [__]
up so I switched to clean hair care and
now I use vague more their shampoo and
conditioner and one like the Peace of
Mind Is everything and second of all
like it's smells so good but there's no
fragrance like it's really light my hair
feels great and I like it's just so good
you don't need those chemicals it's not
good for your hair having bigamora as
your go-to shampoo and conditioner is a
game changer for overall hair Health the
gro revitalizing shampoo and conditioner
kit that we both received has been
fabulous for just overall hair health
and again clean products so give your
hair exactly what it's been craving with
vegamore go to vegamore.com toast and
use code toast to save 20 on your first
order that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off at vegamore.com
toast all right ready for some deer
toasters ready to save the girlies I'm
so ready
hello Jackson Claude love you guys I
have a friend who has been copying me
for as long as I've known her she'll
copy my ideas my fashion my jokes and
just key personality traits and make
them her own I honestly think she
doesn't notice that she's doing this
I'll say something super specific about
a movie we are watching and like two
minutes later she'll make the exact same
comment I also I also have a unique
sense of fashion and she's always
copying me for example if I make wearing
bright orange all winter my personality
trait should randomly say she's obsessed
with orange I used to take it as
flattery but that was annoying and I
hate that my jokes are now hers too how
do I bring this up to her because it's
such a weird thing to go to your friend
and say stop copying me
um
yeah you can't really say anything
without sounding like so petty and for
me I know it's easier said than done but
it's like I wouldn't enjoy being friends
with someone who doesn't have an
original thought and who's just like
constantly copying me like what does she
bring to the Friendship why do you still
hang out with her
I just want to say like I have a totally
different take on this maybe it's
because like
yes jokes I am great at but like no
one's ever like marveled at my style and
like wanted to copy everything that I do
um so I would find it flattering yeah
until a point but I think if anything
like you being like you're the orange
girl and then like your friend shows up
wearing orange like it makes her look
like a loser like you look like cool
like I would kind of just like let her
keep embarrassing herself yeah but I
just don't understand why someone who's
like so unoriginal like what how did you
two even meet no and like why do you
keep hanging out it's like you're
watching a movie and she's just like
parroting back what you said like what
do you guys talk about if you're just
talking to yourself but I also think
there are instances when you can call it
out like okay so you made a comment
about a movie and two minutes later yeah
that's the perfect scenario to be like
girl like I and like make it into a joke
be like okay not you literally saying
what I just said five seconds ago like
call it out to it's like at least maybe
she doesn't even know she's consciously
doing it but like at least everyone in
the room will know and you can do it in
like a funny way and then when she shows
up wearing orange but like yes I love
that you like say something like
living for orange it's giving Catherine
or whatever your name is like it's
giving it's giving Claude but then you
sound like so egotistical it's like you
didn't invent the color well her ego was
only that big because everyone's copying
her and she sounds fabulous I just want
to say no I totally agree I mean orange
we're all wearing it I think we're all
wearing orange this winter do you see my
outfit today it's orange it's orange in
the winter in the winter
um
that's really annoying I really don't
know what you can do I think here and
there you could say like wait I just
said that or wait I just did that but it
does kind of make you look small it's
like petty you're clearly the more
original creative fabulous friend why
must we put down this one who doesn't
have no but you know at a certain point
like we're all adults like okay you
don't wanna you're not so creative
that's fine nobody has to be not
everyone has to be like the most
creative person but like own it like
stop just like be the not creative girl
don't be the the girl who copies that's
[__] embarrassing yeah
it's better to like own who you are as
like a not super like out there creative
person than to like try so hard to be
someone else try to be someone you're
not yeah like we're trying bad for this
girl
me too I like have sympathy for the she
doesn't know how she is yeah she has
like no sense of self
yikes
um so like just take it from that
perspective like don't be so hard on her
she's like she honestly sounds like a
loser
like for real
okay ready
hello Jackson hello Jackson mcturd
love you girls I love when I go to
McDonald's and I order the MC turd I
know but they're always out of it it's
so annoying because it's so popular yeah
it's just like the mcplant yeah I listen
to you guys so much and I'm pretty sure
my baby's first words will be good
morning Millennials my sister and I are
huge fans and we've been dying to get
your input on the situation
I'm a military wife Slash new mama so I
live far away from me thank you for your
service amen I live uh far away from my
friends and family I had a baby this
past June and I went back to working
from home in September I found what I
thought was a perfect babysitter we only
need her once a week she's a young
college age girl who claims to be dog
friendly and great with babies she takes
good care of the basic needs of my baby
feeds him changes him puts him down for
naps but anything other than that she
sucks this girl leaves my baby in the
playpen as she raids our cabinets and
fridge and freezer and cleans us out I'm
talking Costco sized package of
tortellini gone after lunch
I caught her putting leftovers water
bottles tampons in her backpack side
note when she started babysitting I
asked her what she likes to eat so I can
keep it in the house for her which I do
she ignores my dog when he barks or just
tells him no and locks my dog out of the
room so he can't play with his baby
brother which causes him to stand
outside the door and bark relentlessly
in a panic until I text her to let him
in if we cancel babysitting less than 72
hours in advance we have to pay her for
the whole day
she asked us to pay her when my grandma
died we are desperate because there are
slim pickings of babysitters where we
live but I feel like she's taking
advantage of our desperation and
kindness I really want to stay working
because it's remote so I can keep my job
and my license as we move from state to
state every few years what should I do
should I fire her quit my job and just
be a stay-at-home mom full-time or am I
being too critical and as just an
overprotective mom sincerely a confused
new working mama
the hunger thing is interesting and the
tampons like tampons like college kids
are always on a budget like I could see
them like throwing an extra water bottle
in their backpack but honestly the
tampon things give like gives me pause
it kind of sounds like I know this is
crazy but she she sounds homeless well
she's only with them one day a week
right that's what she said yes
um no but I understand like what a
college age person like like when you go
back to your parents you steal toilet
paper yeah but one she's not her parents
but two like the food stuff even though
like Costco size tortellini is a lot of
food like you take like you open the
door to be like we'll have food for you
so like okay you can't judge it that you
eat so much but like no taking tampons
like that's just like that's
inappropriate
um no and Jackie at the end of the day
taking something without someone's
permission is stealing no but like
taking the tortellini without asking and
eating all of it and eating and being a
Kaza like because that's what she's
being and she's taking advantage of the
situation that's it's uncouth but it's
not
I think Fireball considering your
pickings are slim but it sounds like you
have all of these issues with her I I
would try as hard as you could to find
someone else because you shouldn't get
your job you should keep practicing it's
one day a week and it's not even like
she's amazing with right the kid she
doesn't understand it's bare minimum
yeah I mean anything she eats in your
house on your time she's 100 entitled to
um it's the packing up of stuff without
asking permission that I just feel like
is a slippery slope it's just taking
advantage and it's not
it's not right and yeah I mean the dog
thing I kind of understand me too
um because you have a little baby and
it's hard to watch both at the same time
and sometimes like I'll be doing
something with Harry and uh and I'll
have Brew like outside the playpen just
because like I'm watching Harry
um so that I I do sort of get though The
Barking is annoying
maybe you have a sit down and talk with
her if you really can't find someone
else just kind of like a statement of
work being like
um
expectations and we're happy you know to
get you things that you want when you're
here you're welcome to what's in the
pantry but we find it to be a little
rude when you take things home with you
it feels like you're taking advantage of
our kindness right like if the girl was
working and got her period and can I use
a tampon of course but to stock up on
your supply from someone else's house is
an insane thing to do yeah and I'm
sympathetic because college kids are
more often than not on you know strict
budgets and so all right if she took
like two tampons but like the whole
thing taking the supply of everything it
ain't right no like go take it from the
women's center yeah right there are
especially at college so many resources
yeah like go to the Health Center like
the health clinic yeah grab some stuff
that's so weird to do that when
someone's home is insane yeah and you
want and when someone's in your house
like you need to feel comfortable yeah
so
I think I I would focus on finding
someone else like it's I don't know
where you live but there's someone
yeah there's other colleges students
right right bulletin boards things like
that Twisters drop a comment like if you
live kind of in a small town like
where's the best place to find a good
babysitter I think there are also apps
and Facebook groups
yes
um okay third and final hello Jackson
Claude I have a dilemma and I need your
help this is a little you know IRS IRS
tax dilemma that I'm really interested
in I have a group of friends and we go
all go skiing a few times a year there's
like 10 of us so it's a lot of ducks to
keep in a row the leader of the group
Megan is almost always in charge of the
Airbnb this is fine with everyone
because she is the one who knows
everyone the the most and can really
Wrangle the crew a few weeks ago Megan
made a comment to another member of the
group that struck us as odd she said if
the IRS ever calls you about the airbnbs
will you tell them that you're a client
of mine
we always split the airbnbs evenly but
she is is she writing them off and
getting free trips and charging us how
would I even approach this if so it's so
awkward to bring up money and I don't
want to accuse her of something if that
was some kind of weird joke please help
a broke toaster
um she's definitely writing it off yeah
that doesn't mean she's getting it for
free though
no she's still paying it's just a tax
write-off so like she's saving some
money on her taxes
um that's just [__] weird you should
just be like I'm not lying to the IRS
like yeah thank you and then moving
forward like all right one of the other
girls somebody does the Airbnb yeah I
don't think it was weird joke like I
think she really I don't know what
business she's in but it's somewhere I
guess she would have a client go to an
Airbnb and she can write it off
um just when she asks you just be like
I'm not lying to the IRS so figure it
out what kind of business y'all in
that's what you just sounded like it's
did I don't know what you said I don't
know what kind of business she's in I
don't know what kind of business y'all
in she is writing off the Airbnb yeah we
love like a uh resourceful Queen like
not gonna lie no
implicate other other people yeah
nothing means lying like you'd find a
loophole
loophole it loop-de-loop but you can't
lie to the IRS and you can't ask your
friends to lie that's the worst part is
like getting other people involved yeah
and this is just I don't think this is
isolated in terms of her fraudulence no
she sounds like a deeply problematic and
fraudulent person yeah like she's
writing off everything yeah and like it
sounds like the IRS has maybe already
made contact with her like like they're
on her tail and yeah this is weird stay
away she should not be in charge of
booking the house but also
um I think you guys are like oh no Megan
does it because it makes sense she
wrangles us but no Megan has made
herself the person who books the house
she's taken advantage of you you guys
think you like Let It Be Megan's thing
but she took it and let you think it was
your idea you think you're playing Megan
but Megan is playing you [__] yes so
that's what's going on with Megan don't
lie to the IRS
Megan Megan
um speaking of this new episode of good
guys with Josh and Ben if you are
feeling sad that this episode is over
there's also just there's so many great
podcasts out there on toast News Network
and your media just like check out check
them all out all of them everyone a full
report by tomorrow by tomorrow of what
was your favorite
obviously the toast but then what the
redheads but then and then The Statler
oh my God I have got to get in the habit
of calling Margo's podcast best of both
which is such a good name for her
podcast
um but to me she was and always will be
this is well she is the snatchler that
doesn't change yeah that's true on a
personal front yeah but she is the best
of both
and she has
the best of both yeah
are you guys that's our show tomorrow we
are back
we love you thank you so much for
listening to the toast to the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify iTunes Stitch your public video
I read a castbox all the places we've
listed podcast Finance to Chelsea five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and a wickedly talented we are Ben has
still not responded I just double
checked damn thank you great day
everyone we'll see you tomorrow love you
bye